there have been next to no laughs at
this comedy club in kingston for 18
months
with only room for 60 it's intimate
venues like this
relying on the country breaking free
from restrictions
it doesn't exist if we can't have people
come into a space and be together so
but of course you know we want people to
do it safely i'm not advocating anything
that would be unsafe but
we don't exist if we can't be performing
in this because we never know what's
going to happen until right before
then we have to go okay well what are
they going to throw at us this time is
it going to be one meter is going to be
meter and a half distance you know
what's the mask rule
not having any guidance in advance is
crucial to making a good decision that's
safe for us and safe for our customers
this frustration the prime minister will
likely face from thousands of businesses
especially as promises of so-called
freedom day in england
are being scaled back it's clear that
the cases are
going up and that the levels of
hospitalization that are going up
clearly it's a matter of serious serious
concern
from where you were at the end of may
that's fair isn't it yes
that's certainly fair but this won't
necessarily mean
returning to lockdown scientists are
unlikely to suggest that restrictions
should be tightened further
but there are signs that some rules will
be here to stay
things like face masks and guidance on
working from home
in order to make the roadmap
irreversible the answer may be more
jabs in arms the double vaccinated are
far better protected
but just over half of adults in the uk
have had both doses
a few weeks delay buys more time
if there is a delay i think the majority
of people
are actually already wanting it to
happen
and the data suggests that quite clearly
i think the danger is
that the government acts a bit like like
a parent who thinks that the public
aren't capable of dealing with the truth
and can't be told the full information
don't treat the public
as fools and don't treat the public as a
problem
treat the public as a partner tomorrow
is decision day
but it's likely june the 21st will be a
summer solstice
that may feel far from celebratory ash
naharinag
sky news